hey guys it is the 27th of January today
my name is justin mcconnell and you're
watching games but news Marja sauce is
having a sweet time with a big jump in
first party revenue thanks to Minecraft
and it seems that playing games on the
hololens may be something you actually
want to do Microsoft's earnings from
first party games are already up
seventy-nine percent or 171 million
dollars if you prefer the gigantic
number the figure from the finance
recorder from october to December mainly
includes sales from minecraft as well as
the launches of halo the master chief
collection and thoughts of horizon 2 as
for that hollow lens microsoft CEO such
an adela has spoken about gaming with
the augmented reality device saying it's
getting clearer how the games people of
today will evolve to mind-blowing
experiences in the future when designed
for the mixed reality that Windows 10
and hololens create currently there are
two minecraft hololens demonstrations
being developed although they're
currently very much work in progress
according to the developer if you like
your games hard or not at all then you
probably want to hear about what CD
Projekt RED having the store for the
witcher 3 its difficulty as with most
RPGs your difficulty mode choices are
varied but if you prefer the higher end
of the spectrum there will be an
insanity mode the developers said they
couldn't reveal much about the mode just
yet since they're still working on it
but as the T's are one idea being thrown
around at the moment is that if the
player dies at all you'd lose your save
game like literal yolo mode CD Projekt
RED are promising though that while the
mood is designed to be super punishing
it'll still be fun finally a new
Dragon's Dogma game is coming it's for
PlayStation 4 ps3 and pc and it's free
to play I lost you didn't I Capcom has
announced that the upcoming Dragon's
Dogma online set to land in 2015 will be
free to play and supported by
microtransactions
players take on the role than awaken
character in a new region called
Listeria you'll then journey through the
world with three other players who are
either ai-controlled or humans the
combat will be similar to the previous
Dragon's Dogma installment and the four
confirmed in game jobs are fighter
canter priests and shield stage Dragon's
Dogma for ps3 and 360 was created by
some of the key people behind the devil
may cry and Resident Evil games who are
back for this new installment even
though the original wasn't a massive
seller / Capcom in the West it found a
hardcore cult following let me know down
in the comments which difficulty level
you like to play on and why you can head
to gain spot for more stories on
invidious graphic card error and you
stopped cracking down on fraudulent game
copies that is all the good stuff that
I've got for you today that I'll be back
with more news same time tomorrow so be
sure to check back with me then